hmmm reality
here we are alive experiencing something
together on this planet orbiting the
star were feeling we're alive
and that in itself without anything else
is beautiful
beyond that things get complicated
if we stay with that first part
just that there is something instead of
nothing and that there is sentience to
experience
this universe
and that may be a purposeful thing
that this was created so that what
emerges can experience itself
now again everything beyond that is
complicated because being alive and
experiencing creation is in itself
beautiful in itself it's enough
and then beyond that all of the things
are added
all of the politics of the economics
all of the money
the love the hate the pleasure the pain
but going back to the most simple thing
the most first principle thing is that
we are alive
and now
we are sharing this beautiful place home
together
and given sentience given this ability
to feel given this ability to take in
sensory inputs and process them to
experience the universe to be the
universe experiencing itself we get that
and that by itself is enough from there
we've lost that ability to just be
harmoniously with that to be
harmoniously together on this planet
live harmoniously amongst each other and
amongst the ecosystem that sustains us
so that first principle thing needs to
be reimburse at the most deep
fundamental level
and by doing that everything else
becomes so much easier everything else
becomes
natural right now it's artificial
the amount of problems that we have the
amount of issues that we have have all
arisen from our loss in that first
principle
how many of the children that are being
born into the world today are lacking
that first principle how many of their
parents the adults and the grandparents
also are lacking that first principle
being alive that there is something that
we are experiencing that together that
in itself is beauty that in itself is
enough and if we treat it that way if we
remember that everything else becomes
easier but at its fullest not just a
mental izing of it but at its fullest
deepest embodiment
and many say that the complications that
have arisen from the first principle
being forgotten of the complicated
issues are purposely supposed to be
there
that that is the lesson that we are
learning that by disconnecting from that
first principle all of these issues have
emerged and that this is the story this
is the game that we are playing the
illusion of separation from creation
that is the game that we're playing and
we have to remember that we are all
creation remember that first principle
everything else every other issue in our
world becomes easier to take care of
when we remember that first principle we
live much more harmoniously with each
other and with the ecosystem that we
reside in
and it can be on a moment-to-moment
level anytime it can be remembered and
embodied anytime that breath of air is
because of creation your ability to
perceive things right now is because of
creation your ability to feel something
is because of creation the ability to
have other friends in this world is
because of creation your ability to feed
yourself nurture yourself nourish
yourself all of those things are because
of creation to remember that on a
moment-to-moment basis and share that
with your friends families people that
you work with people online carrying
that mentality with us all the time it's
game changer that first principle that
first principle will change our entire
civilization and put it on a more
positive trajectory going forward
remember that embody it and move forward
with remembering that first principle
I love you very much thank you